jerry west joins us here on the rich
eisen show finally that was stressful
jerry that was stressful i think we
thought we called you at a country club
first but we got you on now so i'm happy
well as i say you guys gotta get your
numbers right
we gotta get our act together this is
like ridiculous here that's what happens
when they let me they let me out of
prison put me back in charge
jerry what's your favorite all-star
memory
here's some obviously uh
i played in 14 all-star games and when
they first started they were so
different
uh because you know you go there and it
wasn't a really big deal it was
obviously
for the players involved to get selected
it was an honor of course
and
today you know you have your fans
involved and so it was completely
different process for getting there
but uh you know today you can take uh
some cities that
will put their players on there and
they'll really rally tremendous support
behind them and obviously some players
that get there are because supportive of
fans in a respective city and everyone
pushes certain players because they
think they played well enough to get
there so it's a completely different
process you know
at one time you went there for the
all-star game and now all the other
festivities the dunk contest the
shooting contest the skills contest
and it's really like
i assume one big party i don't make it
a habit to go to these games because
they've changed so much
and uh the other things are part of the
excitement for the fans and
obviously the kids and the sponsors and
it's kind of a respite from uh you know
an excruciating difficult schedule for
these kids this year jerry what's it
like for you watching the change in the
players as they become
marshall and i were talking about this
earlier with charles barkley
more
self-absorbed more focused on themselves
the changes in their attitudes towards
the game that you love so much
well you know
i think it's easy for people to sit back
and criticize but one of the things
times doesn't stand still susie
um you know the advent of the game the
three-point shot has changed everything
the
i think the loosest of standards at one
time that would not be uh acceptable
today in terms of
you know the carrying the ball uh the
walking that goes on the uh
the violations of the rules
and again this is a really tough game to
uh
to
officiate because the size skill
and the quickness of the game but my
goodness i just see walking um
all over the place um
you know it's just amazing to me it's
something that they tolerate now that
wouldn't be tolerated before
and i think it's the advent of the euro
step which many times is not three steps
about four steps
it's simply impossible to change
directions
90 degrees or 100 degrees unless you
carry the ball but
i think we better get used to it as part
of the culture now and
it's about entertainment and allowing
the players the biggest stage they can
to show off their
ball handling ability
some of the incredible things they do
physically so the game is changing but i
think the biggest change
has been the three-point shot
at one time coaches there are a lot of
different coaching styles some people
more protective of controlling the game
a number of shots taken
a lot of times because of a lack of
physical equipment on their team a lack
of players that didn't have this great
skill so they tried to mold them into
some kind of players but today my
goodness
you don't see a lot of teams score less
than 100 points a day in any given game
jerry i just and i and i'll ask you this
question because i i don't know how how
you're supposed to do it how do you play
defense now in the nba is that is it
like
did you just not
because it's it's it's hard i mean
everything's a foul in today's game well
it's become more difficult and uh as i
say over the years people come to the
game to see something we have some
unbelievable athletes in this year and i
i heard you talking about lebron james
now i want you to think of what this
guy's accomplished for so many years
uh physically he's just been so dominant
his whole career
now you know as he's gotten older
i think he's gotten to be a better
basketball player i really do he just
doesn't always
rely on his ability to go into the
basket
use his size and his cleverness to bump
people off and make shots
he really can shoot the ball down and i
think that's been the reason he's been
able to survive along with this
unbelievably gifted mind that he has and
it's become a profession now and
today the you know the amount of
money that the kids can make today
don't you think for a second that they
don't want to put themselves in a
position in life
to be able to walk away from the game
and say oh i can start a career a new
life
based upon the fact that i don't have to
rush out and get a job to try to support
myself
so you have to give it to the kids and
as i say the nba uh is progressive
and obviously things that fans like to
see
some of them are really spectacular and
you go back and look at him he said oh
my gosh the guy walked about six steps
doing it and um
but again
they used to be so strict with the rules
but
i think it's a sign of the times i mean
there are a lot of rules that were
strict then not just applying to
basketball but
life in general
and we do not have those rules today and
they're becoming a lot less
a lot less strict on a lot of things
that people do in their regular lives
much less
uh in sports and
you know we just got through the super
bowl my goodness uh
if you watch you know passes being
thrown um
how subjective it is for
past interference my goodness uh
and at the wrong time the game early in
the game they won't call them late i
mean late in the game they will not call
them
unless the offensive team has it
and i just see a complete difference in
all sports you know hockey i don't know
i think it's one of the most fun games
in person to see
i do not know some of the penalties
they're calling i've been
i watched hockey for years when i was a
player i just see all these home games i
love dockney
but as i say certainly the rules have
been
restricted but also
to allow these players who can do
so many remarkable things and uh it's
pretty to watch
but in the process it might be
it might not be legal at one time in the
league
hey jerry a question and i don't know
this about the rules of basketball
can an office of guy get called for
flopping is it an actual
foul
like is it
like well they call it as i say it you
know there's a few people in this league
or they're really clever
really clever
and the officials today every time you
hear a guy drive if you just listen or
if you're listening on the air guy
screams always screams before him shoots
the ball yeah so he's hoping to draw the
attack
attention officials
they do listen and it's
that to me is
go to acting acting school sometimes
you'll do better but again this game has
completely changed
uh you know i watched a game last night
which
i watched a game every night or some
game and watching the
knicks and
the nets last night
the knicks had a another
insurmountable lead and imagined to get
some way somehow to lose a game
they've lost a bunch of games where
they've been in 20 points ahead and lose
it in the last quarter and it's hard to
believe
as well coached as they are but it also
shows you that
players who keep playing
and putting more pressure more pressure
and it usually applies on both ends of
four more aggressive defensive play
which forces quicker shots
bad shots you miss them
these leads can evaporate really quickly
in the league and i think that's why
people don't leave the games anymore
because they can
teams can come back and particularly if
they work at it
oh jerry i mean somewhere stephen a
smith is still in a fetal position oh my
screaming at the top of his head the
knicks are a national disgrace i mean
jerry that game was ridiculous was it
not
well they played the lakers here in los
angeles and were way ahead
i think they played portland they were
way ahead
and again these games are never over all
you have to make
and if you just think about it let's say
that you're ahead by
15 points okay
you come down and miss two shots
and and you miss him the other team goes
down makes a three okay
all of a sudden they make two turnovers
the team comes down and makes another
three and a foul shot four times down
the court you might be
make up 12 points
and uh so
you know
fans get frustrated because new york
wants a team okay and i look back in
time
and uh you know they've had some very
good teams there they won uh they won
championship back there but
uh probably
that was the place i really wanted to be
drafted to be honest with you
i thought i was going to get drafted
there you know being from west virginia
we played there all the time the fans
were very accepting of the fact we
played a very up-tempo game
and i thought it would be a great place
to play but it turned out
again you know some things life doesn't
always provide what you think is going
to happen
and to have an opportunity to come here
in los angeles and
you know play my career here and be
involved for so many years
it was probably the right thing it
happened yeah somehow that worked out
for you jerry west hall of famer
legendary icon jerry west hey i'm
curious your thoughts
on the ben simmons trade and the trade
that went down obviously
um what are your thoughts on
on
mental illness becoming part of the
equation here and how this turned out
well you know i spoke about a long time
ago and i wrote a book and talked about
the issues i faced in my life and most
issues i've faced in my life
are how to deal with my emotional issues
and
my goodness i've lived like a lot of
people some really dark moments in my
life and
i don't know what sets it off but you
know going back to
some of the things i saw as a kid which
were
not conducive for loving nurturing
families
it was really difficult for me and susie
you know just yesterday i don't know why
yesterday but yesterday i had one of the
worst days of my life yesterday
it was you know something that comes and
goes
obviously for athletes to have to cope
with it in a world where people the
first thing they think about
is how much money they're making that
has nothing to do
with how you feel about yourself
there's a lot of times i felt like a
failure as an athlete because
we get we are almost like teasing the
fans of los angeles you know lost eight
out of nine times in the finals
and when you
that's the time that you just kill
yourself to perform at the highest level
and everyone says well
you know you do it
you do it for the franchise no you don't
you do it for your teammates
and also the fans who support you
and it doesn't
you know the franchise benefits from it
okay the enormous success
but there's such a personal feeling for
me
that you never deceive your fans uh you
never keep teasing them and
listen we've all been teasing their
lives in a lot of ways and i certainly
have and i didn't like that feeling and
i just felt
we had let the fans down go there's
twice in my career that
in the height of my career
i didn't want to play anymore it was
that painful and
as i've gotten older i think things
personal things bother me more now
i'm more likely to lash out
than i have before and that's not my
nature normally suzy it's not
but you just there's certain things that
really frustrate you and
i think that the the things that you
don't accomplish as a team uh for the
people who support you and really care
uh and really care um that's what
matters most
jerry west here on the rich eisen show
marshall faulk susie schuster jerry i
think it's really
it's big of you it's gracious of you to
share that i think many people would be
flummoxed to hear that uh that somebody
as iconic as jerry west can have those
dark moments too oh my gosh
i have a lot of them suzy and as i've
gotten older
um
you know i get there's things that just
frustrate me and suzy name might not be
you know how you treat people is the
most important thing in the world
i don't care who you are if you don't
treat people with respect and kindness
it's one of the most derogatory things
that
everyone on this earth regardless of who
you are
you know if your people have a lot of
success and unfortunately we
look at success and say well that person
got a lot of money has nothing to do
with it giving
giving of yourself
and my goodness i wish in my life that i
would have been able to make the kind of
money these people would do
today i would help make a difference in
their community i wouldn't want anyone
to know it
and i try in my own way to keep things
that i do that are personal to me giving
back
i just don't want anyone to know it
and
there's things i love to do for people
and particularly for young kids
who don't have uh the best family life
they need a place to go and where
there's a protective nature to it
someone to go there and pay attention to
them
someone then go and teach teach them
something
and more importantly teach them
discipline about how you interact with
people
these are the things today that i wish
we would
instead of talking about all these
excessive things that we talk about and
let's care about the people that get
lost where young kids and
people very much like me when i was
young
unless i'd picked up a basketball i
wouldn't be alive i wouldn't be had a
chance to
to live my life and more importantly
live some of my dreams and
i'm a big reader and there's certain
writers that say things in essence
that have resonated with me for other
years and the late joan didion
uh
unbelievable writer and
incredibly
just incredibly brilliant and touching
certain people
she's an amazing writer and i can
resonate with her in some of the things
she said
she said something that has stood with
me i did not know this until later in my
life
she said people tell them stories order
tell themselves stories in order to live
well when i was a kid
i told myself stories i didn't know who
joan didion was
i had no idea
i used to
tell myself stories
because i didn't want to go going to go
on a home and face what i might see
and so my feel good times when i was out
there
i could make every last minute shot with
find a way to put a second back on the
shot a shot clock
i could be the announcer i could be the
referee
i could be the coach
and i would not leave there and i was
eight or nine years old and this
everything i did was solitary
and uh no one else liked to do what i
like to do i used to love fishing all
the time going to woods you know
wondering what i was going to see
and
but that was the thing that really
resonated me i was telling myself
stories
because i didn't you know when i went
home hell i wouldn't feel very good
about myself
and i've often felt that that was kind
of a stepping stone for me
in my life when i thought back of it uh
back on it
there's been a lot of times in my life
says i just want to give up
and
you know i say some people are just
they're charged differently
um some people jovial unhappy
some people are not
i go through days when
i don't say a word even at this point in
my life
and uh it's because i'm
in one of those dark places and and um
and i've see i see i've seen kelp before
um
and frankly it doesn't help me i can't
find
what i would play uh find a peaceful
place sometimes
and that's why meditation can help so
many athletes too and if you haven't
read it i would say to anybody out there
listening a year of magical thinking
maybe jerry that's one of the books that
touched you so much but i know that that
was one of the books that john didion
wrote that got me through some hard
times
amazing amazing book
but
you know i read about leaders uh not
about
i lead a read about history and you know
everyone's so much uh caught up in
history but we don't study history
anymore
you should learn from history okay
and unfortunately
we don't want to learn from history
learning from history is the greatest
teaching aid that any leader anyone else
could have in this world
it is just
it talks about the pitfalls of life you
know if you look at wars my goodness
i mean it's it's ridiculous that people
kill each other
um
over ideologies religion
uh you know some person thinks that he's
going to conquer the world
these are the things that he looks at
millions billions and billions and
trillions of dollars that have been
spent on military
equipment what if that money was spent
differently in these countries that
are constantly
struggling to survive their citizens
lack of food uh lack of
infrastructure
to me it would you know i would like to
see the money spent on something else
that would benefit kids
and people that are growing up with some
dreams that might not ever have a chance
to achieve them
jerry west safe travels we'll miss you
and hopefully you'll have you back in
studio when you come back well thank you
guys so much my best and
going to cleveland for an all-star game
i haven't gone to one for years and
unfortunately uh
not unfortunately but uh i'm sort of
going to be required to go there but
always
enjoy cleveland
hey cleveland jerry's on his way jerry
thanks again
thanks for the visit i'll see you when
you come back
cleveland the greatest i love jerry west
so much there i said it on the air i
love jerry west just said
man the logo man classy wonderful
wonderful gentleman been lucky to call
him a friend for almost 30 years
don't take it for granted hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here